still the same questions after four and
a half years can we afford no deal prime
minister
tomorrow another trip to brussels for
more of them
the pm still hoping you've got to be
optimistic you've got to believe that
there's the the power of sweet reason uh
to
to get this thing over the line but i've
got to tell you
it's looking very very difficult at the
moment but sweet reason has not
chimed with this man the eu chief
negotiator who is stark in the middle of
big european countries with competing
agendas
more than ever the brexit is a school of
patients even a
university of patients but after quite
some patience
a resolution on part of the brexit
conundrum
on how to deal with northern ireland it
came in a statement from these two
michael gove and the european commission
vice president
mariot sefkovic they said that with
regards to the protocol
on the republic of ireland and northern
ireland an agreement in principle has
been found on things like
how to control border posts and entry
points for checks on animals
the supply of medicines and food
products to supermarkets
today's agreement is over the most
controversial element of boris johnson's
last brexit deal how to avoid a hard
border in northern ireland now sorting
that out
was a necessary precondition to avoid a
bus stop in there but also to smooth the
path
to a uk eu trade deal but that doesn't
mean that there'll be one indeed in some
ways having an agreement over northern
ireland
makes it easier to do no deal whatever
the outcome of the trade talked life in
northern ireland
is likely to feel quite different after
january the first
one toe still in the eu single market
the businesses in northern ireland
have the opportunity to enjoy the best
of both worlds access to the european
single market
because there's no infrastructure on the
island of ireland and at the same time
unfettered access to the rest of the uk
market
hang on how can access to both markets
be the best of
both worlds why can't england scotland
and wales have the best of both worlds
as well
northern ireland is in a unique
situation
the expectation is that it could look
quite different to the present situation
there's going to be a lot more
red tape than there's ever been things
like transit certificates safety and
security certificates
you're going to need export health
certificates which are very very costly
they can have tens of thousands of
pounds
to a load going to a a supermarket
uh and and quite frankly we are a very
high volume
low profit margin industry so even small
pulse rises
uh have a a really dire effect on on the
bottom line
one route leads to a deal one route
leads to no deal
to a certain extent speculation is
pointless
sam coates sky news